dieser stadtteil im nordrhein
westfälischen velbert wurde komplett mit
schnellem internet ausgebaut gut
komplett stimmt nicht ganz denn diese 16
doppelhaushälften sind leer ausgegangen
drumherum gibt es modernes schnelles
internet aber hier nicht
die telekom hat kurz vor ihrer haustür
mit der verkabelung einfach schluss
gemacht
ich finde das schwachsinn da oben dass
da oben haben die glasfaserleitung und
diese 50 meter runter ja die sind den
anscheinend egal wer als kunde ich nutze
eigentlich das internet zum arbeiten und
das ist überwiegend gar nicht möglich
weil ich einfach viel zu lange warten
muss weil seiten immer wieder abstürzen
er selbst die gegenüberliegende
straßenseite ist entsprechend vernünftig
versorgt und wie gesagt die neuesten
häuser und jetzt hier stehen noch gar
nicht und das sind sachen die sind für
mich nicht tragbar nicht im 21
jahrhundert die telekom verlegte neue
glasfaserleitungen und setzte diese
grauen verteilerkästen dadurch wird das
internet schneller aber nicht bei
joachim appelmann und seinen 15 nachbarn
die sind nicht an die schnellen
leitungen angeschlossen deshalb gibt es
bei ihnen im haus statt
hochgeschwindigkeit nur zeitlupen
internet appelmann und seine nachbarn
leben in der internet steinzeit
keiner fühlt sich verantwortlich und
meine angst ist halt dass wir hier am
ende als weißer fleck in einer gut
ausgebauten infrastruktur leben nur
haben wir dann halt da nichts von
dabei hat die telekom in dem wohngebiet
viel gebuddelt und ganz massiv um kunden
geworben
aber die letzten 16 haushalte waren zu
weit weg von den verteilern ein neuer
kasten hätte gesetzt werden müssen der
telekom war das zu teuer schriftlich
heißt es herr appel man wird über einen
kabelverzweiger versorgt der nicht teil
des ausbaus war ein aufbau eines neuen
kabelverzweiger wurde wegen zu hoher
kosten für tiefbau und technik nicht
gemacht
zur erinnerung es handelt sich nicht um
eine bauernhöfe sondern um 16 haushalte
in einer 80.000 einwohner stadt die
betroffenen menschen sind stinksauer für
mich schon ein bisschen im stich
gelassen ja also ich sag mal die politik
redet und redet und letztendlich
passiert doch nichts es gibt auch sehr
oft stress in
jugend oder im familienleben sagen was
mal so internet geht nicht ich komme
nicht rein was ist wieder
schon allein die schulischen dingen die
telekom hat ihnen dann doch noch ein
angebot gemacht glasfaser bis ins haus
für insgesamt 100 5000 euro völlig
bekloppt deshalb müssen appelmann & co
in sachen internet auch weiterhin
neidisch zum nachbarn über die straße
schauen